[Music]
thank you I'm sorry I couldn't be here
last year I'm delighted to be here
tonight despite the proliferation of
awards these days Oscar remains the one
symbol of achievement in the
entertainment field that is recognized
all over the world the nominees for Best
Performance by an actor in a supporting
role are Richard Castellano in lovers
and other strangers
John Marley in love story Gene Hackman
in I never sang for my father
Keefe Dan George in little big man John
Mills in Ryan's daughter may I have the
envelope please
the winner is John Mills
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well I really honestly was not expecting
to be standing here with with Oscar I I
really was not I was thrilled to be in
the building that I I'm quite I'm but
I'm quite stunned and I'm completely and
utterly unprepared I I was speechless
for a year in Ireland and I'm utterly
speechless at this moment that I I do
want to say that I I think it's a
wonderful choice for me I mean and I'm
really am terrible everything sounds
like a cliche but I'm really enormous ly
thrilled and I do think competitions
rather good and I've been competing all
my life and I'm very thrilled that I've
won this and I saw as we'll always
remember this moment thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]